in this video I'm going to show you an
easier way to rotate a figure about the
origin 90 degrees 180 degrees or 270
degrees so what you would do is you
would draw your pre image like I've
drawn here and then what you would do is
you would take the figure and rotate it
so for example if we want to rotate 90
degrees counterclockwise I would go
ahead and take this and rotate it a
quarter turn to the left
and then what you would do is take like
another sheet of paper and what we're
going to do is we're going to now record
the location of the points as they stand
now so for example a prime is going to
be negative 1 0 B prime looks like it's
that negative 1 negative 2 negative 3
negative 4 2 and C Prime you're at
negative 1 negative 2 1 2 3 ok now what
you want to do is you want to take the
figure and rotate it back into its
original position
ok and now what you want to do is plot
these points on the diagram so negative
1 0 is going to be here that's our a
prime B prime is that negative 1
negative 2 negative 3 negative 4 2
that's our B prime C prime is at
negative 2 1 2 3 and if you connect
those up you can see that's going to be
the image okay the new triangle there if
you want to see a video that I did using
the rules or the formulas for rotating
90 180 270 go ahead and check out the
video that I did here and I'll see you
over in that video